hey everyone and welcome to a reskin of
generation next
yes that's right we are back but this
time we're called console crew because
you know we all love consoles and play
games on them all the time
i'm lucy james joined as usual by xbox
expert jordan remay
what's up playstation pro to more
hussein
this is an asset flip and you should all
be ashamed of yourselves
lazy creators this is happening an
hd remake i was worried that uh we've
been off air for so
long that people might have forgotten
who i am so i've just very handily worn
a jumper that says my name on it just in
case people are wondering which one of
these
is time again it's me uh but make sure
to subscribe we've got new episodes of
console crew every friday
now with added nintendo whoa
oh yeah
this week we had the first nintendo
direct in
here we go in over 500 days
so it's been such a long time it's been
84 years
uh before we delve into the zelda stuff
um
give me an emotion that the nintendo
direct made you feel
tired whoa whoa
just pain just constant constant
pain like i knew going in that silk song
wasn't going to be a part of the direct
but it was still
so sad not to see it there yeah i mean
no silk song no metroid no bayonetta
um how can we hurt jordan specifically
oh no eldon ring look ridiculous
let's let's talk about zelda so the
thing that i wanted to say is did
nintendo forget
zelda's birthday is on sunday if you're
watching this
on the day that we released this episode
uh
yes it's zelda's birthday but when is it
link's birthday that's what i want to
know
when is it international link's birthday
he has many birthdays because he
reincarnates
over and over again regularly every day
is link's birthday
i like your style so yeah big elephant
in the room that
we don't have anything really about
breath of the wild too
other than more information will be
coming later this year
um no mention of anything else like wind
waker hd
or twilight princess hd or what i really
want
because i really really want to play
them um ocarina of time
or uh majora's mask so
nothing but we did get skyward sword
how do you guys feel yeah i'm sure
people are thrilled about that
some people are throwing i will say
skyward sword
is underappreciated and to be clear i'm
not saying it's a good game
i'm not saying it's an amazing game i'm
saying it's under appreciated
um mainly because the motion controls
back in the day were
poop from above and i'm glad that
there's now an option to play that game
without motion controls you can play
with motion controls if you want but
i'm glad i can just press buttons
actually a pretty fun game i found for
the most part a lot of
as they mentioned in in the direct a lot
of ideas that would carry forward into
breath of the wild
also banging soundtrack great soundtrack
the title theme
reversed version of zelda's lullaby very
very good theme
it's not even the motion controls for me
five
feet however you pronounce that name
just
her existence and like constant like
showing up to be like hello jordan i
hear that you're just a colossal dumbass
let me explain to you
exactly what you have to do next i'm
like shut
up please if you just remove her from
the game
i think skyward sword is pretty damn
good and i would play it but i just
i don't i hope that they like cut down
on how often she interjects in the uh
you'll get nicer textures and maybe a
little bit of tweaking to the control
skin
but that's it so sky was good it made
skyward scored
skyward sword makes sense because it's
the 10th anniversary um
evan our astute editor yes he's back
um made a very great point about the
fact that they're not doing anything for
zelda's
35th anniversary this weekend because
it's still
mario's anniversary yeah
and so mario there taking the claim on
the birthday year up until
march 31st so maybe that's when we'll
start getting the zelda stuff rolling in
and he also made a great point it's like
mario had the
mario not mario mario time
it's mario time um made the great point
that
maybe that's when they'll do like the
bundles of all of the older games
for a limited time only or maybe they
just don't give a single
and i like yeah whatever let's give
these nerds skyward sword and maybe
they'd leave us alone for a little while
they'll buy it again for 60 dollars we
can trust them anything they want and
they'll buy it
it should be like someone just leaning
and you're lucky i don't put an
expiration timer on this again
anyway happy birthday zelda i hope they
do some more stuff with zelda i
i want more out zelda give us give us
more zelda stuff
give us bayonet3 okay xbox time now
jordan what has been going on in the
valley of the
jolly green giant this week you know i
started to put that in my head and i was
like
for for people who don't have the
context jelly green giant in the uk was
used to sell
sweet corn green giant
okay okay so we're running with that all
right
okay so xbox has this new thing called
fps boost which i
originally completely thought that they
were going to just like boost all their
first person
shooters but it's and makes way more
sense that it's for the frame rates for
their games uh so they're basically
doubling and quadrupling the
frame rate for certain select titles uh
games like far cry 4 which is getting
boosted to 60 fps a new super lucky's
tale which is going up to 120
fps which is too many kind of a lot
how many 3d platinum frames does that
little squirrel thing need
relax i've never even played new super
lucky's tale it's pretty good honestly
okay there it is i'm like i realize that
i'm just complaining about it and i have
no context
it's a lot like skyward sword it's not
amazing but it's kind of
underappreciated it's cute
there's a character in there that says i
vanish a lot which i'm into oh yeah a
little cowboy the cat yeah
i say the most exciting thing about this
is that there's like mention that
they're adding like little things in the
menu to let you know
which games have the option for you to
turn on the fps boost which i'm hoping
means more badges
to be added to the little squares of the
games maybe
like you'd love better no no no so i
when i was
writing out the run of show i wrote that
down and i was like jordan's good boy
loves him some badges
i love him john's gonna love these
badges and then um
i looked at the screenshot that xbox
posted and it's actually when you press
the xbox button
it's just on the side oh like the whole
hdr thing yeah that's dumb
it's not great wow maybe maybe i'll
revisit
maybe they'll listen to this feedback
and put more badges in in the future
phil jordan says it's stupid then i
guess we have to add the
yeah we as we know big phil watches so
big phil please more badges let's see
the jolly green giant
he used the jelly bean i imagine him
like deciding which fps
game gets a boost just walking around
being like you get a boost you get boost
you get a boost he's just throwing he's
just pointing yeah and they're like why
super lucky style he's like i pointed at
it didn't i so the digital foundry video
on it is really really good and like
everything's
unlocked uh frame rate too and
apparently they were saying that like
the game still thinks it's running at 30
frames per second but it's actually 60
so the game is just out there like
it's changing this is fine this is fine
it's just someone you know when you're
like oh running on a treadmill and you
look away someone's just like turned up
the treadmill while you've been looking
away and you're like
suddenly sprinting and you're like
what's going on i feel like i'm running
but i'm actually sprinting
what do you think of the games list
though
because to me i'm not going back to far
cry 4.
yeah i love that they've created
collated this fps boost
game list and put together a lot of
games yeah i mean
it's a list of games that like i could
not
be at gunpoint made to play right now
like if someone comes to me it's like
you should play ufc four have you like
planned my funeral i'm not doing that
says the man who just grinded out
avengers to level 150. listen
you did what i did why are you playing
me on blast like that michael
listen hawkeye is coming kamala just
needed to go up
one point so i was like easy peasy i can
do that obviously he still took me four
hours but oh hot guys coming you don't
give a [ __ ]
about her like listen i am a clint
defender
matt fraction clint barton i have never
once
heard you ever define i am a hawkeye fan
i am a hawkeye fan
uh kate is good but like they're pulling
from the matt fraction era
clint barton run so i'm excited about
that
hopefully they bring in the tracksuit
mafia um who says bro a lot yeah but
like
seriously i'm not playing sniper elite
four or ufc four
uh or your watch dogs do get a grip xbox
fps boost some games we care about
for playstation before before we go to
you evan
please cue the music but not enough to
get us you know flash gmc aid
devil may cry action
i'm just playing it in my head all you
need is the first four bars
yeah i wonder if you know how they drift
in tokyo where they make deal sense
controllers is that where sony makes it
probably not
but the uh the age-old the most annoying
issue in modern gaming drift
has appeared on a new platform it was
formally exclusive
to nintendo platforms now multi-platform
problem
drift so a bunch of tricks truly truly
really cross-playing cross-platform
cross-fighting
cross-play features yeah sony's like
look y'all were complaining that we
weren't playing ball on the whole
crossfire thing
so we could go a bunch of people started
to report the dreaded
controller drift and uh
just out of everywhere threads have
started to appear
with people tweeting about getting drift
almost like you know uh
planned obsolescence works where
suddenly everyone who's got an iphone
at the same time goes well my battery
life is absolutely a bed
it's kind of like that like a bunch of
people have started um
reporting that they got joy-con drift um
and they they've been also reporting
like about trying to get
um sony to replace it and even though
like
drift is current covered by a warranty
but the longer short of it is
um there's now a class action lawsuit
which sounds serious but like
class action lawsuits are dime a dozen
these days anyone can file them
and anyone can do them they're like
every
everyone is doing a class action lawsuit
at some point over everything
but that's not to uh you know downplay
the seriousness of this issue um so
there is a law firm the same law firm
who filed the complaint against nintendo
for the same issue
um and that man's got a niche yeah yeah
yeah he's got a
yeah like we've got a niche and we're
gonna work it and that i got moved to
arbitration for nintendo
um so they're fine i saw that much what
does arbitration mean it's a
separate process where like the the
parties that are having the dispute
agree to like make a decision after
separately from the court system
i believe my law degree is like right in
the back of my head now it's been
replaced by
just reams and reams and reams of
bloodborne law um
so uh you know someone might have to
fact-check that
but yeah so that has gone um into that
section lawsuit has been filed um and
the the the kind of details of it is
they're saying that sony was aware of
the issue
um because it also kind of impacted the
dualshock 4
but people are obviously less you know
holding their feet to the fire
for that one and more more inclined to
do it with a brand new console with
expensive new kit
um but yeah so there's a bunch of issues
with it and they're describing it as
like the fact that sony isn't addressing
as like unlawful deceptive fraudulent
and unfair
so that's an ongoing thing that's
happening um and
uh i don't know about you but i have
some drift i've got a little bit of
drift
but mine mine occasionally just kind of
veers off to the left
um touchwood i never actually had uh
switch drift but i i
have experienced the dual sense drift
which sounds like some kind of terrible
um sugary drink
yeah so it's definitely just tied to use
right not
just time because i don't have
drift in my dual sense yet but i use my
xbox a lot more than my
playstation 5. i mean it's hard to say
whether it's tied to use like however
it's just a
you know you might just get unlucky and
there's no way to really discern that
right now
unless someone does tear down and does a
full-on like stress test
on it for a wide range of a big sample
size basically
definitely feels pretty soon though like
didn't it take the joy-cons like
six months or so for the first like
drift stories to
come out like so so including in in in
the text of the lawsuit that you know it
alleges that sony's
cannot dispute that it had pre-sale
knowledge of the drift defect in the
dual sensor controller which is why
they're going hard on it
um but yeah that's that's pretty much it
they're like looking for
compensatory damage um related to the
overpayment on the controller
um whether that actually how that ends
up going we'll have to see
but i wouldn't be surprised if it ends
up in arbitration again
and sony sony kind of like does nintendo
took a really long time to acknowledge
drift and also
take responsibility for um fixing it and
their process is still not great
obviously it wouldn't be great right now
because of
corona and and the kind of difficulties
of sending stuff but still
we'll see how it goes first of all i
love the fact that
um we've got tam's legal corner as a new
feature on the show
but i'd be interested in seeing how many
people actually have drift so
tim and i both have it if you've
experienced it make sure to chuck it
in the comments below tell us your drift
experiences because i don't know how
widespread it is right now
beyonce yeah if you have experience yeah
if you have experience drifting
controllers or cars if you've lifted the
cars let us know
how that gone what's your longest trip
has this ever happened to you
yeah let us know
all right that's it for first episode of
console crew
like i said we'll be back every friday
so make sure to like this video and
subscribe
and if you want to join the games
discord dm one of us and we'll let you
in it's a nice little fun
group of nice folks term where can
people find you
you'll find me on twitter to more h
where i'll be talking about
law and bloodborne not law though
definitely bloodborne jordan what about
you
you'll find me on twitter at jm remay
we're talking with alessandro probably
putting together a support group for all
the silk song fans who are just
still waiting still still waiting for a
game we thought was we were gonna get in
2020.
and i'm on twitter at lucy james games
just
i don't know telling bad jokes what i
usually do anyway we'll see you next
week
happy birthday zelda happy birthday
[Music]
zelda
[Music]
you